[Music]
what's it going to take to win this
year's rapid in blitz event I won here
before so I guess I have to be in the
similar mindset and just go for it
I hope I play with them and a good
result because this tournament or open
end is very strong well I understand
that it will be very hard about but at
the same time I applied a few few
matches against energy and I get very
Christian I won both of them and I feel
kind of confident that I can play well
if I would play well or not we will see
first I need to sleep well you could
feel the coolship I think the most
important I think it's going to take a
bit Magnus it's been in incredible shape
this years of course now everybody wants
to take a shot at him and to overcome
him the a good start but easier said
than done I need to play 440 you know
like a injury from chest not to like
think about results
maybe then results will come but the
rapid blitz is normal for me not easy my
results was better in class coaches and
roughly billets you play like three
games a day or even more games during
the Blitz so I think it takes more
energy because there are more critical
moments if you play many games per day
then you have I think much more
attention if you're in good shape and
you have a lot of energy I think you
have good chances to to win or to to to
be on top three or something like that I
think it really all comes down to form
so hopefully I can be more consistent
this time that's always been my problem
was
I'm not very consistent and I've usually
if I have some a good result of one day
I followed up with the mediocre result
on next day I I think the key to to
winning this particular rapid enlistment
is you gotta get a good result in in
rapid and then you can allow yourself to
have one mediocre day and blitz it's
very hard to to know beforehand you try
to do everything the right way but
whether whether you be in good shape
it's hard to say and and there's such a
big cost of having a poor day or two in
rapid and blitz and that's gonna make it
really hard and probably quite
unpredictable as well